donc nous avons la joie aujourd'hui de
vous accueillir pour cette première
visite du monastère qui fête ses 10 ans
cette année patrick gille man était le
directeur des travaux du chantier du
monastère il ya dix ans et depuis il ne
l'a jamais vraiment quitté il revient
rendre service heures et vous avez deux
grands
les gens nous disent on connaissait la
colline avant mais maintenant elle est
habitée même si nous voit pas mais il ya
une vie je crois que c'est ça qu'on a
réussi ses deux de donner une vie à la
colline est ce parce que c'est toute la
colline qui est sanctuaire c'est pas
uniquement la chapelle il y a dix ans
c'était un pari risqué de partir de leur
monastère de besançon les clarisses
vivaient dans ce havre de paix mais elle
savait que si elle ne se lançait pas
dans une nouvelle aventure leur
communauté allait mourir elles ont vendu
leur monastère est vécue en plein
chantier à ronchamp pendant presque deux
ans leur projet a été contestée voire
incompris et les voilà dix ans plus tard
bien implanté quatre soeurs étrangères
ont rejoint la communauté
aujourd'hui elles ont réuni ceux qui ont
construit leur monastère et le nouvel
accueil des visiteurs de la colline un
petit projet pour la star de
l'architecturé ns au piano comme pour
ses autres réalisations il a avant tout
écouter les attentes des soeurs c'est
une co conception cenco et
éco-conception c'est à dire qu'en fait
c'est pas un geste artistique esthétique
c'est une production commune d'un projet
qui doit être heureux à vivre et donc
dix ans après moi je crois que ces dix
ans ce sont de belles années justement
parce que la conception a été partagé
c'est l'association propriétaire de la
chapelle qui avait demandé à renzo piano
ce monastère pour que les soeurs
renforce le poumon spirituel du lieu ça
se voit à la façon dont dont le public
les visiteurs
les pèlerins traversent le site en même
temps
avec le passage par le monastère il ya
une vraie présence permanente la
végétation a fait son oeuvre de loin le
monastère s'efface petit à petit dans le
paysage de près la présence des
clarisses est devenu bien réel